outside scotland yard
another vigil for sarah everard and the
issue of women's safety
despite clearly breaking lockdown rules
no intervention from police tonight
and no arrests the protest here a direct
response to events on clapham common
last night these scenes have been widely
criticized
with claims police were too heavy-handed
images of male officers wrestling some
women to the ground
are deeply uncomfortable but the met
commissioner
has doubled down in her defense of the
officers
she said they'd attempted to advise a
large crowd to comply with covert
regulations
but that some in the crowd had become
hostile and started pushing and throwing
items
they have a really difficult job
they have to make fine judgments they
often don't have
infinite information or all the time in
the world
they have to make these really difficult
calls
and i don't think anybody should be
sitting back in an
armchair and saying well that was done
badly or i would have done
it differently the image of patsy
stevenson
pinned down by officers has been seen
around the world
she disputes the claim that people in
the crowd were hostile
the fact that the police turned up was
just disgraceful because before then it
was a peaceful process
um i was arrested by police for standing
there
i wasn't doing anything um they they
threw me to the floor
they have pictures of me on the floor
being arrested and i'm five foot two
and i weigh nothing the commissioner's
position
has been made all the more precarious by
the home secretary and the london mayor
who said they weren't satisfied with her
explanation
they've asked her majesty's inspectorate
of constabulary
to carry out an independent
investigation
despite the pressures the commissioner
says she's no intention of resigning
what happened to sarah appalls me
as you know i'm the first woman
commissioner i've met perhaps
it appalls me in a way even more because
of that
what has happened makes me more
determined
not less to lead my organization
there are numerous examples where police
have taken a more discreet approach
despite covert regulations last june the
met facilitated black lives matter
marches
some officers even taking a knee in
solidarity with protesters
and just last week in glasgow police
scotland allowed ranger supporters
celebrating their club's league title
win to gather and then disperse without
intervening they should have been
allowed to protest to have their vigil
to come together
in peace and i was very disturbed to see
the police action
i think it was wrong and i'm pleased
it's now going to be reviewed
the scotland yard vigil moved on to
parliament square
with organizers of the original planned
vigil in clapham common
saying that they had desperately tried
to reach a compromise
with senior commanders to hold a more
socially distanced event but claim
they were rebuffed
that they say resulted in many more
attending in defiance
some with a clear hostility towards the
police
resisting male violence resisting police
brutality
it's one of the issues the home
secretary will want to discuss further
with the met commissioner
in the days ahead mark white sky news